[Applause]
in a town still mourning a recent mass
shooting President Joe Biden offered
what little he could for new gun
controls the President issued an
executive order he can enact alone but
with limited effect
in the meantime my executive order
directs my attorney general to take
every lawful action possible possible to
move us as close as we can to Universal
background checks without new
legislation
the action orders the Department of
Justice to crack down on gun sellers who
failed to perform background checks and
to pursue former weapons dealers whose
licenses have been revoked but still
sell it asks the Federal Trade
Commission to issue a report on gun
makers marketing to minors and it asks
his administration to find ways to treat
mass shooting scenes like natural
disasters giving federal aid to those
affected because of our the culture of
our community we have been very quiet
and we have been kind of neglected so
for us to receive this amount of
attention and the support that we do
today means a lot for us but major
changes in U.S firearm laws require
action from a hopelessly deadlocked
congress with nearly all Republicans
opposing stricter gun measures
it was here in January at the now closed
Star dance hall in Monterey Park that 72
year old who con Tron shot 20 people
killing 11 in this Asian American
Community Tron was disarmed at a second
dance hall and fatally shot himself as
police closed in trans access to a Mach
10 semi-automatic weapon allowed him to
kill here with speed and efficiency last
year Congress did pass the first modest
gun restrictions in three decades among
other things they enhanced background
checks for 18 to 21 year olds but
they've done little to slow the pace of
mass shootings in America
in the past several months there have
been dozens of other mass shootings
killing 21 at a school in Uvalde Texas
10 black New Yorkers in a racially
motivated shooting spree at a
supermarket in Buffalo and seven at a
parade in Highland Park Illinois
paying tribute to the victims of
Monterey Park Biden renewed calls from
major new gun controls including a ban
on military-style assault weapons
Universal background checks and repeal
of the immunity from most lawsuits that
Congress gave to gun makers in 2005. so
let's finish the job band of Soul
weapons ban them again do it now enough
do something do something big but with
little hope of Congress approving any of
those measures nothing that comes out of
Washington is likely to prevent mass
shootings like the one that happened
here John hendren Al Jazeera Monterey
Park California